[Music]
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think
tighten the top screw to get finely
ground pepper ideal for soups and sauces
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic one clove simply bash it
with the back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily for a whole head crush
separate into a bowl cover and shake
hard for about ten seconds then simply
pick out the pill cloves so much great
cooking depends on starting with a high
enough heat if a recipe calls for a hot
pan put on early so it gets smoking hot
and always remember to pre-heat your
oven at least 20 minutes before cooking
a clean cook is an efficient my tip for
tiny cooking area is to always have a
waste bowl next to its saved you going
back and forth to the bin never add salt
eggs before cooking them because it
ruins the texture and Dolls the colour
instead save your seasoning to the very
end
[Music]
the key to cooking meat is to make sure
it's at room temperature before you
begin cook straight from the fridge the
muscle fibers will be tight which
results in tough meat and always let it
rest afterwards so relaxed is becoming
tender and juicy line their line going
across put the point of the knife in and
just push through step on is the most
expensive spice in the world made from
the dried stigma of croque